will reconnecting formerly incarcerated
people back to nevada's workforce
the las vegas chamber and hope for
prisoners kicked off the month of
second chances with a virtual webinar
now the focus was on
how graduates from the hope for
prisoners program can regain sustainable
jobs john ponder who is the president
and ceo of the hope for prisoners
program
shared how his initiative has helped not
only graduates but local companies all
across the valley
when you hire someone from hope for
prisoners
you're not just hiring them you're
hiring this entire
army of people that are going to be with
them over the next 18 months
to make sure that once they get inside
your workplace
you know our goal is to make sure that
they're in their sore like superstars
because their success within those
businesses are going to open up the
doors for the next folks
that are going to be coming through now
employers that hire formerly
incarcerated people may be eligible for
the work
opportunity tax credit companies
interested in hiring can visit the
website it's pretty easy to remember
hope for prisoners dot org